[Music]
have you ever sympathized with a
monster I remember as a child seeing
images depicting the legend of St George
slaying a dragon but I didn't have the
reaction to these pictures I was
supposed to the dragons didn't look evil
they looked sad and the older I've
become the more media I've seen where
monsters suffer the less monstrous they
[Music]
seem to empathize with a monster is to
go against thousands of years of
Storytelling precedent the traditional
Mythic role of a monster is to be a kind
of living obstacle typically one that
embodies dominant fears in its culture
of origin the very word monster comes
from the Latin moneri meaning to warn
when a courageous hero van vanquishes a
monster it's not supposed to be tragic
but a victory over a societal anxiety
this conventional model of monster hood
is the one most of us are familiar with
next to Pottery maybe monsters are about
as close to a cultural Universal as you
can get wherever there are people
telling stories there are stories of
monsters but what is considered
monstrous and worthy of scorn or fear
varies across cultures and time so what
one civilization judges to be
irredeemable another might pity and
empathize with it all comes down to
perspective like there's that one scene
in Star Wars where our hero crushes a
monster called a Rancor with a gate
which feels triumphant until you see
this one side character looks so
heartbroken like this creature meant the
world to him and though the rancor
didn't seem like the nicest fellow as a
child this moment made me wonder if the
creature was truly evil or just a
starving animal and a pig
it sympathizing with a monster isn't a
novel concept but it is one that's
evolved over the years one of the most
important turning points in film came in
the early 20th century when Universal
Pictures thrust the tragic monster into
the Hollywood Zeitgeist with the success
of 1931's Frankenstein based on Mary
Shell's 19th century novel about
scientist Victor Frankenstein who
reanimates a creature made from corpses
the film makes numerous changes from the
source material yet keeps the core
tragedy of the central unwanted creation
upon Awakening Frankenstein's monster is
essentially an innocent newborn but
because of his monstrous strength and
appearance he's abandoned and mistreated
by those around him including his own
Creator it is through this mistreatment
that the monster learns to act monstrous
lashing out with anger at a world that
is given him anger in turn and the film
emphasizes that the creature does have
the capacity for kindness if met with
kindness even if just for a fleeting
moment though he cannot help being
inhuman in the eyes of others his nature
is not inherently
inhumane where the novel and the film
differ is that in the movie The Creature
remains infantile Until the End whereas
in the book he becomes eloquent and
cunning committing inhumane acts with
full awareness to punish his creator yet
the novel 2 indicates that the
creature's cruelty stems from its
initial abandonment and the horror that
follows is ultimately the fault of Dr
Frankenstein's hubris the very idea for
the creature came from Mary Shell's
apprehension towards people attempting
to use electricity to revive corpses so
while Frankenstein's monster embodies
fears of human recklessness he is also
innately a victim of that same
recklessness there's the old gacha that
Frankenstein isn't the name of the
monster but the name of the man but from
a thematic perspective it's not that
clear
clearcut yet Frankenstein wasn't the
only 19th century monster novel turned
Blockbuster to come out in 1931
Universal's Dracula was an even bigger
hit sticking more closely to a folkloric
model of monster Hood with a largely
unsympathetic monster threatening the
sanctity of a social good this Dracula
can be seen as a manifestation of us
postwar anxieties over perceived
external dangers coming from afar to
threaten the home as can many of the
universal creature features that
followed yet a surprising number of
these films also find Pathos in their
monsters with the writers aware at least
on some level of the tragedy inherent in
being rejected by Society for something
you can't control so maybe it's no
surprise that many of these monsters
have been reimagined over the years as
more sympathetic and non-threatening
figures asking audiences to empathize
with say a vampire is far from unheard
heard of these days it opened its wings
like this
screeching now you are
vampire and it was
Peter and we're still friends
today the surprisingly sympathetic
framing of Universal's early monsters
can in many ways be traced back to the
1928 silent film The Man Who Laughs the
story of a circus performer mutilate as
a child into having a permanent grin the
central figure of The Man Who Laughs is
neither a supernatural creature nor an
anyway villainous he is only a monster
from the perspective of a public that
will not accept him though likely the
inspiration for the iconic villain The
Joker the original Man Who Laughs never
snaps and becomes the monster everyone
expects him to be in fact he gets a
happy ending despite his appearance
never changing for a movie from the
1920s the film is surprisingly nuanced
in its exploration of the lead
characters lived
experience at the time of release The
Man Who Laughs was lumped in with
figures like the hunchback of notredam
by marketers Under the Umbrella of
universal monsters which speaks to a
callous public perception of people that
were physically non-normative this
tragically Echoes the history of many
so-called monsters in folklore with
werewolf Legends for example likely
related to individuals with hyper tros
a condition that causes hair growth
throughout the body fear of the unknown
or of that which a societal majority
deems abnormal is at the heart of a lot
of monster mths with the label of
monster used to demonize and dehumanize
those perceived as
other in European history fear of the
unknown also manifested in the form of
geographic Monsters the kinds of beasts
that populate the edges of medieval and
Renaissance Maps meant to evoke the
perceived dangers of far off locations
over the centuries Tall Tales of
Fantastical beings from distant lands
and distorted accounts of actual
Wildlife combined with growing
imperialism into a worldview that linked
monsters with regions unmapped by
Europeans by the early 20th century this
worldview merged with paleontological
discoveries to create lost world
narratives wherein adventurers would
discover not Mythic monsters but lost
prehistoric life which they then
conquered in a manner that reflected
imperialist attitudes towards nature and
Indigenous populations and out of this
muddled Mythos submerged King Kong one
of the most enduring pop culture figures
of the last century with a complex place
in the realm of sympathetic monster Dom
coming 2 years after Universal's
monsters broke onto the scene the
original King Kong is a movie of
contrasts on the one hand the titular
Kong feels like the geographic monster
personified presented as a treacherous
embodiment of the unknown that the
Intrepid explorers must subjugate on the
other hand unlike most universal
monsters Kong is at least initially not
the invading figure but the one attacked
in his own home and the film does seem
aware of and sympathetic to this
unfairness on some level not just an
obstacle Kong is given moments that
could be classified as heroic which
later reboots have made more explicitly
Valiant though Kong eventually Rampages
through New York this only occurs after
he is forcibly removed from his original
environment and here the film's
sympathies split once again as Kong's
eventual fate at the hands of the
military is presented as both tragic and
the pre-ordained outcome of nature
clashing with industrial society Peter
Jackson's reboot in particular brings
this tragedy more to the surface but in
that film Kong's defeat upon challenging
Humanity still seems inescapable
which is why it's notable that the
latest incarnation of Kong flips this
Dynamic on its head in that series Kong
is closer to a deity a symbolic reminder
of how insignificant humanity is
compared to the endurance of the natural
world this is also the most overtly
Noble version of Kong ever put to film
presented as an honorable defender of
the ecosystem the original movie might
pity Kong to an extent but the latest
incarn nation is explicitly textually on
the side of Kong and not the humans
pillaging his home he is always the
invaded never The Invader and I think
this transformation means more than
critics give it credit for the fact that
Kong is gone from semi antagonist to
essentially an action hero suggests that
the attitude of General audiences
towards Monsters has changed over the
last
century speaking of which isn't there
another iconic giant monster Monster
Who's gone from villain to Hero over the
decades Godzilla rose up from the depths
in the early 50s ushering in a new wave
of atomic age monsters anxiety over the
seemingly Limitless potential of nuclear
power led to a slew of films where
unfeeling mutants terrorized Humanity
for their Folly though many were the
creation of Hollywood Godzilla was a
uniquely Japanese depiction of
postnuclear trauma with the first film a
somber analog for Atomic devast station
but the more Godzilla films came out the
more the tone uh shifted a bit with the
movies becoming increasingly silly no
longer a dead serious embodiment of
postwar suffering Godzilla became
something of a national mascot a figure
who though occasionally still
destructive was typically contrasted
against a more overtly villainous
monster this change was in response to
Japanese audiences sympathizing with the
character and wanting to to see him as
the protagonist despite his monstrous
form the director of the original
Godzilla ishiro Honda has a poignant
quote on this stating monsters are
tragic beings they are born Too Tall too
strong too heavy they are not evil by
choice that is their
tragedy over the decades Godzilla's
villainy would wax and Wayne through
different incarnations but one of the
most important incarnations came
recently in the film Shin Godzilla this
movie in many respects returns Godzilla
to his roots as a personification of
wartime destruction it's probably the
most nightmarish version of Godzilla
seen on screen thus far a borderline
eldrich being that only brings
Devastation but hidden within the
narrative is a highly sympathetic
portrait of an animal in a state of
suffering Godzilla Begins the film in
apparent Agony a mutant newly created
from nuclear waste barely able to stand
and no matter how destructive he becomes
there's always a sense this is a
creature in terrible pain during the
final Rampage ominous operatic music
plays but if you listen to the lyrics it
seems to be a plea from Godzilla's
perspective lamenting that no one
understands its sorrow if I die in this
world who will know something of me a
downward slope is all I see Shin
Godzilla is an about to save the world
with a majestic dropkick if the film
argues this veritable God of Ruin
deserves your sympathy as well like Mary
Shell's monster he is a victim of
Humanity's hubris a Monster who never
asks to be
made conversely a heroic modern
interpretation of the character comes
from the legendary films wherein
Godzilla is not a mutant but a
pre-existing superorganism from the
perian period that nuclear testing
happened to awaken
this changes the character into more of
a force of nature rather than a man-made
Calamity much like the latest version of
Kong Godzilla is presented as a guardian
of ecological stability in fact those
two incarnations of the characters share
continuity a curious byproduct of this
reimagining however is that like earlier
films that framed Godzilla as the
protagonist these monsters now have
monsters of their own unsympathetic
living obstacles that must be put down
to protect a greater good typically
these villains take the form of outside
threats to the ecosystem most
traditionally
aliens aliens Rose to prominence in
Hollywood in the late 50s and early 60s
stealing the crown from nuclear mutants
as the dominant pop culture monsters so
the fact that the earliest Godzilla
films to frame him as a hero put him up
against aliens is appropriate turning
him into the reigning champion of
monster Hood defending the throne from
new upstarts in the US especially the
alien craze reflected Cold War fears of
invasion the extraterrestrials portrayed
as infiltrators with secretly deviant
appearances and agendas aliens might not
seem like they belong to the monster
category but though cloaked in the
scientific jargon of the Space Age most
mid 20th century extraterrestrials were
still archetypal boogey men
manifestations of cultural paranoia that
need need to be vanquished not all
aliens to come out of this era were
malicious but aliens that could be
trusted usually looked like Spock where
anything nonhumanoid was more likely to
be duplicitous this is a trend that's
continued pretty much until the modern
day there's ET of course but he's
something of an outlier notable recent
works that break from this framing
include District 9 and arriv rival the
design of the aliens in these films fall
in line with the bug Gore squid-like
aliens that terrorized the be movie of
the 1950s and 60s yet neither of these
nonhuman aliens are depicted as
villainous in fact the central conflict
of both films stems not from the aliens
possessing secret plans to invade but
from Humanity's fearful reaction to a
perceived threat as was often true in
the McCarthy era the only monsters in
these films are the ones people invent
and the ones they become in the name of
destroying the imagined Interlopers
a sympathetic monster who exists at the
crossroads of all these themes is the
Gilman from universals the Creature from
the Black Lagoon first appearing in the
' 50s the Gilman was a monster dislodged
from time both in the narrative and in
the era the film was released though
marketed as a Sci-Fi creation the Gilman
fit more with the then outof style
Geographic monster of King Kong's era
and as was the case with Kong the
portrayal of the Gilman man is a
complicated one he is easily the least
aggressive of the classic Universal
monsters beginning the film as more
Curious and only resorting to violence
after being attacked multiple times and
in his own home no less as film director
guo del Toro puts it he gets his home
invaded and then roughed around you know
he was at home swimming in these guys
bar in yet the film itself doesn't fully
break from the imperialist model of
monsterhug with the defeat of the Gilman
framed as largely triumphant this
questionable framing is the reason why
Del Toro chose the Gilman as the
inspiration for the creature in the
shape of water set in Baltimore in the
1960s the film subverts The Classical
monster narrative by making the fish man
basically the secondary protagonist
using his plight as a means of exploring
the systemic inequality endemic to the
era the shape of water makes overt
what's been true for Monster media since
its Inception that portrayals of
monsters often mirror portrayals of
marginalized
groups leading out of the late' 60s pop
culture monsters would become
increasingly decentralized as film
genres became more diverse with their
appearance and level of sympathy varying
greatly one of the last widespread
Trends was the horde of zombie Centric
media that shambled to the Forefront of
monster Dum in the 2010s though the
Mindless zombie might feel purely
unsympathetic
the myth intertwines with an older
particularly tragic form of monster Hood
we'll call the transformed monster
stories Like The Wolf Man and Dr Jackal
and Mr Hyde helped establish the Trope
of otherwise innocent humans who
transform into monsters and lose control
in their monster forms these characters
typically cannot be reasoned with the
sympathy comes from the audience knowing
who they were in recognizing that this
is a fate they would never choose
mainstream zombies appeal to emotion in
a similar way though the aggressive
creatures have lost their Humanity
there's no escaping the fact that each
one used to be human every zombie is the
ending of a Melancholy tale a fact that
makes it difficult to completely close
your heart to them even if they're just
enemies in a video
game speaking of which the most recent
and perhaps largest wave of sympathetic
monsters can be found in the medium of
video games traditionally most games
have stuck to the Mythic model of
monster Hood portraying them as
unfeeling enemies that the player must
overcome it's a format that makes sense
for interactivity games are all about
obstacles enemies make for engaging
obstacles and monsters are a clear
visual shorthand for enemies and yet I
think a lot of players can point to at
least one example of feeling bad for a
virtual monster the first time I
encountered this feeling was when I was
playing Super Mario Galaxy as a child
early on in this bright and colorful
Adventure you land on an egg of a giant
monster that hatches and turns
aggressive you then have to defeat this
newborn life form in order to progress
and it wasn't until my first time
beating this boss that I realized how
sad it is all this creature knows is
violence it's literally the first
stimulus they ever experience I remember
thinking that my actions created this
monster i' just pulled a
Frankenstein
obviously that's not what the developers
intended for young me to take away from
this game in general you aren't supposed
to see video game monsters as thinking
feeling beings which is why when a
developer intentionally subverts this
Trope it can be so powerful the Dark
Souls franchise is filled with tragic
enemies with almost everyone under some
form of heart-wrenching curse or another
but easily the most affecting is CF a
giant wolf who wields a sword but while
this monster might seem ridiculous the
loyal canine is only trying to protect
the grave of its deceased owner and to
make matters worse there's an alternate
route you can take where you bond with
cth beforehand and the Wolf recognizes
you before you do battle it creates an
encounter that makes you re-evaluate
your role in the story in wish you could
choose to break from the cycle of
monster
slaying in the game Skyrim you actually
can choose to break from the cycle in in
this game you play as a predestined hero
tasked with defeating a group of
villainous dragons and you are rewarded
mechanically for slaying these creatures
with useful upgrades for most of the
game's main story this conflict is
pretty clear-cut with the dragons
following the classical tolken style
model of unambiguous evil but this
Simplicity is upended when you meet Parx
an elderly Dragon who has reached
Enlightenment through meditation and now
avoids conflict part of what makes
parthona so interesting is he almost
seems aware of his metatextual role in
the story he basically knows it's his
narrative Destiny to be monstrous and
yet he still
refuses what is better to be born good
or to overcome your evil nature through
great
effort and what's heartbreaking is that
you're nevertheless tasked with slaying
this peaceful being and if you succeed
the game rewards you with greater power
but you can choose never to initiate
this fight and if what I've read online
is any indication most players don't
like Parx people seem able to step out
at the narrative and Trust empathy over
fear fear is Central to the player's
experience in Shadow of the Colossus the
final game I want to discuss in this
video the game puts you up against some
of the largest monsters in the medium
creatures so worryingly gigantic that
all your p panicked mind can think of is
how to survive well you might fear them
they certainly don't seem to fear you
but everything changes when you make it
to the 11th Colossus not only is this
creature relatively tiny compared to the
other behemoths it's scared of you most
video game enemies don't show Fear it's
an emotion that's a little too genuine a
little too human you defeat the 11th
Colossus by wielding a flaming torch to
back it off the edge of a cliff it's
it's a moment that quite intentionally
makes you question your heroic identity
because though it's a cliche to say from
this creature's perspective the monster
is
you humans and monsters have been
inexorably intertwined since our
beginning in fact you could argue humans
used to live in a world of monsters
there used to be significantly more
megaphon species that posed a threat to
our ancestors it's easy to imagine that
life in such a world would be one one of
constant fear but that's not what you
see in Ancient Art of these life forms
you see an incredible amount of care and
reverence for each creature even ones
they' probably had violent encounters
with though impossible to know the
authorial intent behind prehistoric
paintings when I look at these portraits
I feel like the artists were aware that
these creatures were alive like they
were I feel like they sympathized with
them the main reason why I pied dragons
when I was little is because they seemed
like animals minding their own business
until someone invaded their habitat
indeed many Dragon Mists likely stem
from interactions with then unfamiliar
and dangerous animals but to my child's
self these creatures didn't appear
threatening just misunderstood I felt
that if someone took the time to
document their behavior their fate could
have been avoided in a strange way I
think that's part of what set me on the
road towards eventually making this
channel you can't escape monsters they
are culture and history foundational to
how humans Define the personhood of
themselves and others though it's easy
to frame sympathy towards them as a
linear increase the truth is monsters
are always changing always representing
a new fear or a new Avenue for
understanding this is actually my 100th
curious archive video and almost
everyone has featured fictional
creatures to some extent monsters aren't
ever going away but we can seek to
understand
them and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
toate on all things curious see you in
the next
video